mesdames et messieurs merci d'accueillir
les jeunes mariés monsieur et madame
simon toy
je tiens à vous présenter hercule poirot
toutes mes félicitations à la merci
c'est le plus grand détective vivement
je suppose que vous ne m'avez pas invité
à bord pour partager votre bonheur
nous avons le carnac pour nous tous
seuls un chef est assez de champagne
pour remplir unis
chenu quand vous avez de l'argent vous
n'avez aucun véritable ami et ce fut un
succès tu fais et ce que je fais
c
quelqu'un est mort
l'assassin est l'un d'entre vous
et soins le meurtrier est ici aviez-vous
connaissance de rancoeur madame a
l'habitude d'obtenir ce qu'elle dit
je ne sens pas en sécurité
je ne suis en sécurité avec aucun d'eux
il ya beaucoup de conflits et de
jalousie
avez vous vu ou entendu quelque chose
elle n'avait pas la confiance elle ne
l'a toujours pas pour vous pouviez
récupérer larmes c'est moi qui paie sa
cuisine
il accuse tout le monde de meurtre c est
un problème national mais
le meurtre était soigneusement prémédité
pour continuer
m
elle a été coulé n'est ce pas que
voulez-vous que je vous dise
deux meurtres
et vous mentent ils vont me regardant
droit dans les yeux le meurtrier est ici
et il restera ici